صحيح حوالي نار هذه الصور التي وصلتنا قبل
قليل
اقتحام
لمناصري الرئيس البرازيلي السابق
بونسونارو لاقتحامهم مبنى الكونجرس وايضا
القصر الرئاسيه
باولو همم وفيما انصار الرئيس السابق يا
ايفونار يقتحمون مبنى وزاره والكونجرس
وقصر الرئاسه في العاصمه برازيليا هذه اخر
المعلومات
37 للمره الاولى بعد خمسه ايام من تنصيبه
متحدثا عن اهم الصعبه لاعاده بناء البلاد
هذا هو الشعار الذي يتخذه
الانويه
المتحده الامريكيه على خلفيه ايضا نتائج
الانتخابات الامريكيه وقتها نذكر بانه وقت
تنصيب الرئيس البرازيلي قالوا لا رئيسا
للبرازيل همم جرت حفل جرى حفل التنصيب
باجراءات امنيه همم مشدده وهذه هي المره
الثالثه التي يتولى فيها حكم البرازيل الا
انه فوزه بهذه الانتخابات تحديدا اثارت
جدلا داخل الشارع البرازيلي بين مؤيد
ومعارض
ثم نعود الى هذه التطورات خاصه اذا جده
فيها